hello everyone I hope you all have an
excellent weekend we're back at the 1970
Palma de Majorca inter-zonal tournament
it's a Bobby Fischer versus a Brazilian
Grandmaster Enrique making now this is
not the first time Fischer faces making
but we're gonna talk about that after we
we do the photo challenge now I'm pretty
sure it's gonna be an easy one but
nevertheless he is a bit young in this
photo so best of luck to everyone who is
the gentleman here there you have it I
mean the facial expression is there I
mean I'm pretty sure most of you will
know this and a lot of you have
suggested that I should say who is in
the photo challenge of the previous
video in the previous video it was Boris
Spassky but I will not be doing this
because as soon as someone some of you
get to the correct answer in the
comments I will give that comment a
heart and then probably some five six
seven of you after you give the correct
answer I will give all of your comments
a heart and then when someone Scrolls
down you will see in the comments the
first seven comments you will see will
be the correct answer to the photo
challenge so that's basically what I
have in mind I'm some of you might have
forgotten this some of you might not
have but there's there's no need to
explain in every video who was the
person in the previous photo challenge
you know just scroll down and you will
see them so that being said let's check
it out I did not do a video on the
previous game making an official plate
because prior to this game they played
in palma de america 1970 a couple of
months ago before this game there was a
very nice tournament in buenos aires
were two of them met it was a very nice
groom fault game making we drew against
fisher with the white pieces i think it
was around 30 moves or something it's a
very nice game i still didn't do a video
on that game because I am planning to
cover the Buenos Aires tournament at
some point but I did cover a game and
making a plate against Miguel night or
if it is it is really a beautiful game
so for those of you who are interested
in and we can making in some of his
games I will put a link to this video in
the description below feel free to check
it out and as
I did not start this series with Fischer
winning the Buenos Aires tournament as
well
I even though it was a very impressive
victory he crushed the field there as
well
it's not sorry it's not really a part of
the world chess championship series so I
decided to skip it but you know just for
fun these are the final standings of the
Buenos Aires tournament of 1970 I I
think was played in August the palma de
mallorca tournament is played in
December so a couple of months ago so
there have it Bobby Fischer with 15 out
of 17 so zero losses only four draws out
of 17 games that is that is very
impressive
followed by took Markov pan oh girl
given I'd refer chefs kiss miss love and
making there you have making in eighth
place so very nice I just you know I
wanted to show you that Fischer was in
extreme form where were when making
manage to draw a game against him in
1970 Buenos Aires tournament at some
point I will probably cover this
tournament as well and then maybe add to
the Fisher series but not now is
currently we're going after the World
Chess Championship Series but as in that
video we're making faces a big on night
off I did say something more about
American making so feel free to check it
out if you want to learn something but
more about the Brazilian Grandmaster so
that being said let's check out the dis
game we do not have a photo of the match
up but you know that there are very few
photos of the 970 palma de mallorca
tournament feature once again opens not
with any of his main weapons with if or
rather he opens with b3 the names of
each a Larson attack d5 Bishop to b2 c5
we have Knight to f3 and the knight to
c6 and I was sure I did this before the
video for some reason I haven't Knight
to c6 we have III Knight to f6 and now
Bishop to b5 a standard idea in the
names of ish Larson attack white will
often give up this bishop for this night
to give up the bishop pair early but
because he already has this nice setup a
3 B 3 a 2 B 3 and c2 and the nice thing
Carol bishop on B to the the semi open B
file for the rook will
be you know compensation enough for the
for the ruining of the pawn structure we
have Bishop to d7 and now castles by
Fischer ecigs
b3 Bishop to e7 and now Fischer captures
on c6 Bishop captures and Bishop
captures you don't want to play pawn
captures as we've just explained that
okay you do capture towards the center
you kind of improve your sense of
structure structure a bit but it's no
compensation as like we've said the
semi-open B file for the rook is you
know not all that great now so after
Bishop a c6 we have Bishop captures and
now Knight to e5 and of course making
goes rook to c8 not allowing Fischer to
double his pawns Knight to d2 we have
castles and now f4 Fischer of course
wants to complement his dark square
bishop by placing his pawns on a nice
III and f4 dark squares where he will
gain further control of the of these
nice central squares Knight d7 offering
a trade of knights and here we have
Queen to g4 you I mean you don't want to
do something silly like play h6 here as
you have to see that the bishop and
queen are eyeing g7 so after Knight
captures attacking the Queen it's game
over you either lose the Queen or you
will capture the night and get
checkmated so making of course goes
Knight characters on e5 captures on e5
and now to avoid checkmate he plays
Bishop to f6
we have rook to f3 Fisher does a nice
rook lifts Queen to e7 and now the other
row comes to f1 so it's very very easy
for Fischer to develop his pieces he
gave up his light square bishop but he
does have the the rook pair is nicely
doubled on the F file he does have a
very nice special Pawnee v and still he
has to figure out how to get the knight
from d2 to a more active square we have
a 5 here if you play something like g6
the you know start the defending before
there is any threat here that's not
something a grandmaster will usually do
here you can simply choose whether you
want to go rock h3 or how we want to
proceed here but you don't want to give
white any targets just yet as a f5 is
not immediately a threat
so first a 5 we have root 2 G 3 and now
Bishop captures on e5 pawn captures only
5 and now f5 it's often the situation
where you will have to decide how to
defend GSM will you play g6 or will it
play f5 so the Queen can guard the g7
point here if you put something like g6
this will immediately be met with rook
to f6 you will never be able to push the
F pawn anymore and white plane will be
very simple Rocco come to h3 Queen will
come to h4 the knight can easily come
into the game this will be this would be
winning for white
so after f5 after F captures and if I we
have f5 e captors on f6 Fischer does not
mind opening up the F file but also by
playing f5 Fischer wins a pawn so we
have e captures on f6 rook captures on
f6 and now I'm sure all of you can see
how to win a pawn here you know it's
it's a nice little trick you know feel
free to pause the video here and try to
win a pawn here for white so I will give
give it a second if you want to just you
know try and do it as you know it is a
Monday so you might be a little bit lazy
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
pawn grabber and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show Queen
captures on g7 of course Queen captures
enter now rook captures on f6 the Queen
cannot capture back as the rook pins the
Queen
so Queen captures g3 H captures and g3
and now rook to e8 defending the pawn
here and here Fischer goes for e for the
top engine recommendation G for simply
pushing the pawn preparing to meet King
g7 attacking the rook with the g5 and
cementing that rook on f6 g4 we have a
for Knight to f3 pawn captures pawn
captures and King to g7 and now g5 as
we've said he 5 is coming now Fischer
plays nice to h4 you know it would be
very nice if he could get nice to a5
with check into the game so Bishop to d7
preventing this and now rook the d6 a
very nice way to activate the rook
Bishop three six and now King to have to
simply improving the position of the
King King f7 I will rock the b6
attacking the b7 pawn rook to e7
defending the pawn and now II four
captures captures and we have C for now
and of course Fischer does not want to
trade down he wants to play b4 pushes
pawn to a dark square and all of these
pawns will now remain targets for black
Fisher does not want to push c3 any time
soon because he doesn't want to allow
ideas like rook d7 and then the rook
will be able to come to d3 this way it's
a very nice point that prevents the roof
from infiltrating his position we have
Bishop to g4 strategy for if white can
get King f3 g4 and Knight to f5 then
it's pretty much game over
so Bishop to g4 preventing this Fischer
goes King to e3 we have rook to d7 and
now g6 a very nice pawn break through
that that allows Fischer to you know to
go forward King to f8 if you capture
then after Knight captures there's
really no defense against this beautiful
fork which will check the King for the
rook and for this Bishop whatever you
move you will always be able to fork
something here so after g6 King to f8 we
have G captures on h7 threatening h8
Queen rook captures on h7 and now Knight
to g6 check King moves and now Knight
captures on e5 and now you can see that
all of these alone ik bones are still
targets the better when g4 is under
attack
you have to eat remove it or guarded
making goes Bishop to c8 and now comes
Knight captures on three for King to d8
and now Knight to d6 we have a rock to
g7 King to F to King to c7 and now
Knight captures on c8 rockin captures
and here we have rook to desex and there
is nothing more to do here
Fischer is up three points and the
Brazilian grandmasters grandmaster
decides to resign as there is well it
was reasonable before as well but you
know you
sometimes you don't resign when you
should but rather for for some reason
you keep going for a couple of more
moves but now there's a really no point
in continuing playing this game yeah
that's the game around 21 of the Palma
de Majorca 19 1970 inter-zonal
tournament a Bobby Fischer versus the
Brazilian Grandmaster Enrique making and
like I said feel free to check out I
will put about doing to the PGN of the
making versus Fischer game from 1970
Buenos Aires and also a video I made on
the enrique making versus miguel night
or also a very nice game dude I suggest
you check it out for the game but also
to learn something more about enrique
making also known as I believe it's
Makino they call him so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you are in joyous to enjoying the Bobby
Fischer series so far I would like to
thank Christoph Uretsky Guilherme
gallows and the Richard sand for a
contribution to my channel thinking a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon we have 2 more videos in the
Palma de Majorca tournament and then we
are off to the 1971 candidates matches
but both both of those videos I believe
I will save for tomorrow for for this
evening I have another video planned so
thank you all and I'll see you soon